let's go to the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
is the number we're gonna try our first
caller from the 2 1 4 area code caller
from 2 1 4 tell us who you are and
what's on your mind today - are you with
us
yes David Pakman can you hear me yes we
can hear you who's this hi David my name
is Frank macwrite a longtime subscriber
yeah whatever I always just have some
questions about sort of the judicial
system and what could possibly happen
with Trump and all the you know the
Russian collusion so my question is is
when a person gets wrongfully convicted
and spends you know 15 20 maybe even
their whole life in jail and eventually
it's either found out that they're
innocent
isn't it in I don't know how this works
exactly but basically aren't they saying
when that person has pleaded pled their
innocence and the judge and the jury
says you're a liar we're sending you to
jail so isn't that sort of a he-said
he-said she-said thing they're obviously
wrong so why wouldn't the same thing
apply to say you know sessions and all
these people going up and either clearly
lying about things how can they not do
the same thing to them or throw the book
at them and then hey you're you're
basically committing perjury by lying to
us to the FBI yeah we know that you're
lying or we feel that you're lying
why how is it that they're able to get
away with with not you know that not
happening to them it's just so there's
understand what you're saying here's the
confusion in it if you're accused of
some crime like you know battery on
someone for example each side is allowed
to sort of tell the story as they
experienced it
witnesses are asked questions etc and
then there's the question of credibility
and it's true that the reason that
witnesses might have differing opinions
is because someone is lying which would
be perjury but it's also possible that
the different witnesses just sort of
have a different recollection of how
things went and the jury can decide
who's credible and who
when it comes to Jeff sessions for
example the crime itself would be
perjury at least with regard to his lies
in congressional testimony perjury as a
crime is very very hard to prove and
that's why if it were easier to prove
perjury Frank you would see people who
testify in criminal trials in a way that
does not seem to reflect the eventual
decision of the jury you would see more
of them charged with perjury secondarily
after the primary trial is over you
don't because it's really hard to prove
perjury because you have to have an
intent to deceive and I'm not saying
that Jeff Sessions didn't have an intent
to deceive but it is just really hard to
prove perjury and there's also this an
unfortunate reality that those in power
tend to get away with these yeah I mean
Jeff Sessions Attorney General top
lawyer in the country right who's gonna
go after him yeah you're not wrong Frank
but but it's just very difficult to
prove perjury particularly against
people like the Attorney General okay
thanks for that now say hello to Pat as
well all right yeah Pat is here and he
is loving it and thanks very much Frank
appreciate it